échange tendu hier en suède alors que
l'escaladé tensions entre l'ukraine et
la russie ne cesse de prendre de
l'ampleur anthony blinken et sergueï
lavrov se sont rencontrés en marge de la
réunion annuelle de l'eau et c'est eux
elle est chef de la diplomatie
américaine et russe sont entamées ont
tenté d'entamer un dialogue alors que
moscou accusé l'otan de rapprocher son
infrastructure militaire des frontières
russes washington dit vouloir faciliter
un retour vers les accords de minsk tout
en menaçant la russie de graves
conséquences ce matin l'ukraine a appelé
l'otan à rejeter toute exigence russe de
garantie toujours réunis à stockholm les
membres de l'oas et eux poursuivent
leurs travaux le programme de la journée
avec notre envoyé spécial david kelly
fin
une deuxième journée - chargé qui hier à
une ultime session plénière a lieu elle
ce matin plusieurs prises de parole se
succèdent il est question de la crise
migratoire à la frontière polonaise de
l'épidémie de communes 19 qui affole de
nouveau l'europe mais aussi de renforcer
les accords de minsk voté à en 2014 en
pour à désamorcer l'escaladé de tensions
à la frontière ukrainienne une situation
qui met en danger la sécurité européenne
et il y aura une conférence de presse
finale à 13h30 un sorte de s'éloigner de
clôture à l'uni de la présidente
actuelle de l'eau et se passera le
flambeau à la pologne qui accueillera le
29e meeting l'année prochaine ce qu'on
peut retenir justicier en tout cas est
bien c'est que tous les représentants de
l'organisation pour la sécurité et la
coopération européenne sont
particulièrement attentifs à la présence
militaire renforcée à la frontière
ukrainienne anthony blinken le chef de
la diplomatie américaine s'est montré
particulièrement virulent envers la
russie craignant une invasion de
l'ukraine il accuse le kremlin de
saboter les accords d'helsinki signé en
1975 et visant à renforcer la sécurité
européenne ce a dit lavrov a subi de son
côté les attaques à répétition des
différentes délégations occidentales
présentes à stockholm en pour ce meeting
et c'est d'ailleurs sur ce point que le
chef de la diplomatie russe a insisté
lors de sa conférence de presse hier il
a exprimé son désarroi vis à vis de
l'otan 1 face au manque de
considérations de l'otan vis-à-vis des
propositions russes pour la paix et il
dénonce un comportement agressif de
l'occident envers la russie n'a cessé de
répéter que la russie n'avait aucunement
l'intention d'envahir à l'ukraine
l'objectif pour lui et j'espère que l'ol
ira dans ce sens et d'optimiser les
discussions pour trouver une solution
diplomatique
stoppez les confrontations à travers le
dialogue afin d'éviter un ce schéma de
guerre froide un schéma qui se redessine
peu à peu à travers l' europe 1 selon
cbre